hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the on the incredible
unbelievably strong arm that shall
destroy everything that stands in my way
and here we go ah oh I thought that was
gonna do more bear with me happy ah
maybe I'll just do a little more ah how
and wait for it
ah oh hey you want your punch
wait Boop Oh Renard's right off the bat
you shall never defeat me I might not
even a scratch how about a little bit of
hit did horribly haha what about my arm
i er might be able to hurt you exploded
into me alright hey didn't I just kill
your brother huh how big writing your
other eye
massage therapy I'll show you a massage
I roll a one I gently wah I thought I
was gonna gently caress his back I
gently caressed him to pieces it's my
special skill and apparently wait wait
what are you saying I didn't get a sense
oh hey how's it going we doing a fist
bump yeah bro bust out the fist bump
get ready friend oh oh I was too amazing
you seem like one handy man I appreciate
a guy makes puns but not that much
though have you ever
ha ha ha bringing the crotch over how
many times can I punch you in the crotch
please just over and over and over and
over and over again Wow
oh I thought that was gonna kill you pan
apparently I need a more little a little
more gusto to my gumption we're playing
the game yeah we're playing the game all
right called gimme you die oh boy I win
are you doing arm I'm just a floating
arm I forgot I don't actually have a
body I'm literally just an arm wait what
are you supposed to do oh you're
supposed to stand there and get ready to
die cuz that's all you're good at I
never did nothin to you hey you got in
my way you could have just as easily
gotten out of my way I mean I really
hope this goes to your grundle because
that's where I really want to punch you
ah
no Pam thank you are you bigger than the
last guy seemed like it might be a
little bit bigger than the last guy was
oh no snappy comebacks oh nothing to say
to me nothin to say to my glorious arm
you shouldn't do that dawg well now that
you put it that way
I'll just put down my fist hey if you
lose your left arm your right arm will
be left
that's desk [ __ ] you Wade new kind of
handshake
yeah it's the one where I punch you
through your heart and then show it to
you it's awesome can you wait to do it
cuz I'm gonna do it 10 damn you're tough
such a weak punch
oh wait I'm dying yeah pretty much hey
man how many of these guys do I gotta
plough through cuz I'll plow through
them all I'm good at plowing through
pigmen with my fists what am i doing
what am i doing you know what frankly I
don't even know what I'm doing anymore
you gotta go left - so Vaughn oh let me
help you get there like that oh hey big
arm it's not that big I mean it's pretty
big I mean I
goddammit I got a pretty good arm
nothing look at me weird
oh you look at me weird either did you
saw the goat in the entrance I might
have don't really remember no he died
here we go we're gonna go do this
Piper's me Oh how many punches did these
guys need before they learn the lesson
that I'm better than them even though
I'm kind of invading their home here you
shouldn't do what this oh no I did that
let's talk it through we should have
thought of that before I decided to fist
you my fists were made for talking and
that's just what they'll do and one of
these this fist is gonna plow right
through you ah
wow that was a shaky one how long was i
holding that in for sorry you know this
get a little pent up in my arm got a
really give it a nice shake it's my
massage and something my fist will
massage your crotch
Oh Oh another one what top arm not much
dead guy been a funny so today hasn't it
not really
I've just been taking my time doing what
I want to do which is fisting lots of
pig okay
well why am I still playing this game
are you really gonna go this far just
for me absolutely I am I don't know what
other secrets await me I should have
stopped playing a while ago you don't
understand how long it takes to warm up
this bad boy of an arm here need a
little tender loving care if you know
what I mean oh that's a mean joke
ray fat Omo God my eyeballs not no more
I'm not even gonna fight you anymore so
now is the arm what a waste of time but
a good stress reliever was actually kind
of fun
busy when I was able to punch away hey
let me massage you go away thank you all
so much for watching check out the other
end patience for more cool games that I
played in the past and as always I'll
see you in the next video
a complete shift I know exactly where
you in this endeavor love